même la ministre alors que
l'établissement français du sang fait
état d'une situation très critique avec
des stocks stream en bas je rappelle que
les habitants de guyane et de mayotte
pour des raisons diverses ne peuvent
toujours pas donné leur sont depuis
avril 2005 un arrêté préfectoral a mis
un terme à la collecte de sang sur le
territoire guyanais en raison de la
présence de la maladie de chagas cette
maladie qui est considéré comme un
véritable problème de santé publique sur
le continent sud-américain et en
amérique latine où 15 à 20 millions de
personnes sont affectées entre janvier
90 et mars 2005 15 cas humains de la
maladie de chagas ont été diagnostiqués
dont 6 et guy en guyane est cependant
c'est sur cette base que la préfecture a
décidé de stopper la collecte de sang en
guyane aussi une étude du haut conseil
de la santé publique on date mars
dernier indiquait que la maladie de
chagas a été très rarement notifiés chez
decca l'humain en guyane et que cette
parasitose ne constitue pas un problème
de santé publique en guyane plus de
quinze ans après l'arrêt de la collecte
de sang guyane d'importants progrès ont
été réalisés en matière de détection de
la maladie de chagas la transmission par
transfusion sanguine peut désormais être
évité par un dépistage systématique des
dons de son la guyane par le biais de
l'institut pasteur dispose depuis 2016
d'un laboratoire p3 plus capable
d'identifier les virus à l'origine de
syndrome clinique graves comme la
maladie de chagas ce dépistage est
aujourd'hui pratiquée dans de nombreux
pays notamment les états unis le japon
et le brésil ou 100 % des donneurs de
sang sont ainsi des pistes et depuis
1995 madame la ministre je sais votre
gouvernement favorable à une égalité de
traitement sur l'ensemble du territoire
national aussi pouvez-vous m'indiquer
quelles sont les leviers que vous
comptez mettre en place pour restaurer
une véritable politique de collecte de
sang en guyane je vous remercie madame
la sénatrice finir aorte la reprise de
collecte de sang en guyane présente
l'avantagé de constituer un pool
disponibles localement tout en
renforçant un niveau au niveau national
un vivier de donneurs de phénotype
sous-représentées dans la population
courante des donneurs de sang cela
permettrait aussi de mieux répondre aux
besoins transfusionnels des receveurs
notamment dans les antilles et nous en
sommes bien sûr persuadé pour envisager
cette reprise la dgs a demandé à la
santé publique france 2 réalisé une
analyse de la situation épidémiologique
dans ce territoire l'analyse réalisée en
août 2000 21 montre que la guyane
restent particulièrement exposés à des
risques infectieux pouvant affecter la
sécurité transfusionnelle notamment au
vih ou acheter élevé à la dan et au
virus de l'hépatite b pour ce seul
dernier virus l'on peut craindre une
perte de 5 % des poches de sang ce qui
n'est pas anecdotique de plus
conformément aux critères de sélection
des donneurs de sang les donneurs ayant
séjourné en amérique latine qu'est-ce
que vous citiez ou de retour des zones
endémiques présentant des risques de
maladie de chagas pourrait également
faire l'objet de cette contre indication
pour ces raisons de santé publique par
ailleurs la guyane est particulièrement
touchée par l'émergence d' arboviroses
en raison de la présence de vecteur d'un
climat tropical et d'une proximité
géographique avec les zones endémiques
la guyane compte et 294 100 de taux 294
1146 habitants 1er janvier sur ces
chiffres et compte tenu de la
structuration de la population par
tranche d'âge il pourrait être attendue
une collecte d'environ 7000 par an sans
préjuger de la perte de dons lié à la
présence d'agents infectieux ce n'est
donc pas négligeable
loin s'en faut mais nous privilégions la
sécurité sanitaire pour l'instant en
conclusion ce territoire reste
particulièrement vulnérables aux risques
infectieux pouvant affecter cette
sécurité transfusionnelle il est
également menacée par les endémies les
épidémies darbo virus qui nécessiterait
une mise en oeuvre une adaptation agile
de mesures de prévention contre le
dépistage génomique virale voire l'arrêt
total de collecte au vu de ces éléments
la reprise de la collecte en guyana
paraît risqué et n'est donc pas
immédiatement à l'ordre du jour dès que
les conditions le permettront elles vont
faire l'objet d'un suivi régulier
reprendront bien sûr